tony is on the line in tampa question
for Ken Coleman today hey Tony what's up
hey Dave hey Ken are you doing good are
you sir
doing good just lost my job this morning
I'm 24 years old going on 25 and I just
lost my job and it was a six-figure
income so you know a hard job to find
what in the world happened and what were
you doing so I've been in the car
business my whole life kind of just got
thrown into it the whole family you know
everybody's in the car business for the
same company
I was selling bought the cars first
place every single month and you know
some of the cars that were selling they
had you know bad CARFAX I'd work with a
guy for five days straight and the
CARFAX would be bad and I decided to
leave the CARFAX you know out of the you
know I didn't show the guy the CARFAX so
I guess that could have been a lawsuit
or something and they ended up firing me
it was mercedes-benz so you know they're
real strict with everything you leave
the toilet seat open you might get
clipped well first of all we're sorry
this is not a fun day but I want at
least encourage your heart for a moment
you're gonna survive you've got to learn
from this anytime something like this
happens you don't want to move on from
this you want to take as much personal
responsibility as you need to and then
figure out okay what do I learn from
that not let that happen again and move
forward so six figure income we've got
to ask on the Dave Ramsey show where you
at financially are you where are you at
in the baby steps do you have any kind
of emergency fund
yeah I've been putting a little money
away I know my jobs real strict and the
security there's not too good I'm just
by you know knowing where the managers
are at mentally and that kind of thing
they're just real strict with everything
I've only worked there and I said
six-figure income but I've only worked
there this is my third month there and
my first second and this month I'm all
in first place with a perfect CSI which
is you know your surveys that come back
so my customers love me but I was
thinking to the motion more than I was
with my head so I know that's where I
went wrong
well Tony so were you at do you
an emergency fund at all what is it how
much um yeah I have about 15,000 dollars
saved up do you have any debt yet they
do how much my bills every month or
right around two thousand a month yeah
but how much debt do you need to pay off
if you look at all the money you owe how
much how much debt do I need to pay off
on this are no debt to pay off I'm
renting my apartment and my car is
leased I know you hate that Dave but it
is leased alright Dave I'll let you
handle the money stuff in a second
here's what you need to do Tony you
really need to I think you ask yourself
the question why did you do what you did
which got you in a situation where there
was a clear company policy and you
violated it and they take that stuff
serious and as a result you're out of a
job so you really need to reflect on
that we don't wanna beat up on you but
that's important secondly do you love
sales you're 24 do you like to sell yeah
I love to sell in certain environments
so there's certain places I've sold that
that I didn't enjoy on the first real
job that I did like was Mercedes the
clientele the money of course and the
cars I enjoyed selling the cars all
right you're 24 where'd you go to what
did you go to school for did you go to
school and what was it for what was your
major I started college and I was just
gonna get a business management degree
because I had no idea what I wanted to
do so I was like just to go to school
for something I ended up not going or I
ended up stopping school after about two
years you know once it started coming
out of my pocket I just really you know
didn't care about what they had to say I
was more interested in making money and
that kind of thing so for a couple years
I was a professional poker player okay
well Tony you're all over the place so
I'm gonna give you a couple pieces of
advice and this is something you're
gonna need to do actively first things
first is you've got a little bit of a
cushion with that $15,000 you're single
I'd get rid of the lease obviously Dave
can this Dave can speak to that but I
want you to sit down with three people
you can make it five or seven I don't
care but some people who really know you
they care enough about you to tell you
the honest truth they'll be blatantly
brutally honest with you and I want you
to ask the question of yourself and then
let them answer it which is what is your
greatest talent what do you do better
than anything else and then what do you
care about if you love selling but you
want to sell something that lines up
with your values I mean it matters to
you then that's where you need to be
heading but before you even make that
big decision you need to get employed
and you need to lick your wounds here
and also learn some valuable lessons
Dave Tony my son is 25 and this is what
I would tell him if I heard this story
from him number one you have a
tremendous upside you have a gift with
people and you have the ability to sell
what sometimes comes with that is a BS
artist and you've been biessing even on
the phone here toilet seat up is way
different than freaking not giving a
CARFAX report you should have been fired
you deserved it not because you're not a
good salesman because you completely
violated the thing here I'm a Mercedes
customer you completely violated that
you would have been fired if you were
working for me and I would have cried
because you're such a good salesman when
I quit when I fired you and I would have
cried for you because I wouldn't want to
break your little heart but you man
you're just completely stepped in it and
you cannot allow your your gift with
people to think that that entitles you
to cut corners that's the poker thing
that's cutting corners that's the going
around the carfax thing that's cutting
corners your gift with people doesn't
give you the right to cut corners it
demands that you go right through the
middle and that integrity become your
number-one goal posts that you check
everything on from this day forward if
you'll take that with your personal gift
with people you're gonna make $200,000 a
year for the rest of your life you're
gonna be very wealthy you're gonna have
a lot of healthy great customers because
I can tell you this about you you like
selling a quality product Mercedes a
quality product and you like dealing
with intelligent customers because most
of what most of Mercedes customers are
well-heeled
they love that product because it's a
quality product most of them are very
successful themselves they're easy to
sell to for that reason again I'm one of
them but you got to take that other
little piece of this and
digests that part of it from today and
make that your goal post so I'm gonna be
the first one in your corner like Ken
said put three people in your corner
that loves you enough to tell you the
truth
you have a tremendous gifting young man
you can be anything you want to be you
could be the CEO of a major company with
your ability to deal with people and
your ability to sell but you can't you
will never achieve that if you shortcut
if you think you are the if you think
you get to go around the side of
something because of your verbal
gymnastics Kim you can you and I both
have that ability and so it's talking to
both of us I've done the exact same crap
when I was his age here's the deal Dave
this is a road block or a stop sign that
he created for himself and it's a gift
at 24 to go wait a second this is a
temptation for anybody who loves to sell
you know this any others know how to use
a word properly and there's afraid
there's a thrill in getting the deal
done yep and it'll cause us to be
tempted to cut corners like you said
Dave and end up getting ourselves in big
trouble know why you love to sell and
love what you are selling so you're not
tempted to cut corners so if you get
this lesson from this firing you'll look
back when you're 34 and let stand for
and you'll say this is the best day of
my life if you take the lesson away that
they were right they were not petty
toilet seat up is petty you tried to
match it up with Betty it was not petty
it was deserved but you're a good man
and you've got the ability to make big
money and do the right thing with this
gifting and you're gonna you're gonna be
somebody dude you call me back and I'll
help you I promise
this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]